what does it mean to tap into a well
when it comes to story
so yeah in this in my book the three
worlds of screenwriting i use the
metaphor of a well
because for me wells are you know i mean
the desert they needed obviously to
kind of provide life blood of you know
of water
but like water to survive you can't
really survive in a desert without them
and i don't think we can survive without
stories
and so for me tapping into a well is
taking that metaphor and expanding it a
bit
and and digging into either other movies
you've seen
um or your imagination or your memory
and
literally drawing up water which are
stories to kind of feed the
the tribe and i always just like the
idea of a well because whales are
mysterious you know they go down
into some sort of a groundwater and the
groundwater seeps everywhere and
connects
everything else so i think that there's
something like the collective
unconsciousness that jung talks about
is in a well you know you kind of you
never know what you're going to find
down there
it's going to be surprising to you
hopefully but it can also be really rich
and life-giving so for me that's what i
mean by tapping into a well
i think i got the idea from overhearing
a
um a composer talk about how when he
composed music
sort of classical composer that
sometimes it felt like he was just
tapping into an underground river
and the music was this river just
flowing and if you could tap into it he
could just listen to the music
and for me if a story comes to you like
that that's that's amazing so
so yeah it's esoteric but it for me it
talks about
uh the creative process in a way that's
really real
for me yeah i like that you think a lot
of writers are tapping into this
they could it could be a well or even
air
up above you think that's something that
when they get into like this right
mindset
and they're in their favorite writing
environment definitely i think
it's beautiful when it happens it's
sometimes difficult to get there
and the point of my book is to help
people get there but often we can feel
stuck
and we're not in that space of flow and
flow is also like this
flow reminds me of like a river where a
well can draw from in a way
yeah it can be really difficult to get
to that space but when you're in that
space as a writer you kind of recognize
it i think
when the characters start almost
behaving and talking
by themselves and it's like this weird
world that you've imagined but it's
alive
then we're then we're in the flow of
writing and
that for me does feel a bit like drawing
from a well so i think that's yeah that
flow the underground river that we sort
of tap into
it can also be a lightning bolt from
above there's been many you know angels
inspiring us the muses inspiring us
there's mean a lot of stories as to
where
ideas come from but i think you know it
when you feel it when you're writing
it's great
and it's like and when for me time stops
things slow down i don't eat
i don't worry about anything i just
write when you read about some people
who've written
famous works or famous songs they don't
know where it comes from it just
the song comes the story comes that's
that's an amazing space if you can get
there
it's interesting that you say that some
days it's very difficult to get there
because even
with runners or even people who walk
there is sort of like a walker's high or
runner's high
but sundays it doesn't happen it's just
either you're off
or the world is off like some tragic
story is out there
and you can feel it around you and it's
just like i can't get to that place
today interesting
can you not get to that place even if
you run for 20 for a while
does it advantage you just come or does
it sometimes never come on the whole
right
for me sometimes it just doesn't come
it's amazing i don't know and and i
don't know if it's just
it's more me or it's the environment or
it's too like
you know if it's more traffic yeah let's
say you're trying to
and so you're stopping and starting and
you can't really be around that that's
interesting because i think from a
writer's point of view
sometimes you can write and the whole
session is frustrating and you're like i
didn't get to that place i'm a failure
this is terrible
but you just have to go again and that's
that can be very difficult i think
like really really difficult yeah and
you have to push through
and just get out of vomit draft as i
call it environment draft just
you know just be vomited out and even if
it's terrible
somewhere along the line once you've
done that and you go and rewrite
you you may hit that space again but it
can be very limiting for people i think
it can be frustrating right it can be
frustrating
even as you know it's surprising jogging
can be frustrating
i've just started surfing which has
never really been frustrating it can be
frustrating but it's always pleasurable
when i leave the water
but it can be very frustrating but
really what what just because you're
waiting for a wave
and if it doesn't come or you're not
catching it at the right time no more
like if the conditions are terrible and
the waves are everywhere and they're
hitting you and it's like crazy and it's
chaos and you just like
and you can't catch the wave sometime
and you paddle the bell and like
the wave just goes past you and you're
like
i've literally shouted like i've
actually paddled on a surfboard and i'm
paddling and then i
i miss the wave and it turns into
pounding the wave
so i think it it's what you bring to it
as well i think you know this is why i
mean surfing has
taught me about um what i bring to the
surf
if i'm in a frustrated mode that it's a
way of releasing it and i think maybe in
writing it's the same
you were saying about you know jogging
it can just be you maybe what you bring
to the jog before
and that's also why conscious writing
and meditation is kind of important
because you kind of
you're aware of that it's not writing
that's the problem it's
maybe and it's not me that's the problem
but it's just everything that i'm
bringing to it
and so there's a bit of a freedom in
that yeah
you